So in the next game I somehow
just had a technical problem, so
I'm missing another 20 seconds, but
I would probably have wasted them
on the way anyway,
so
the classic setup with
Luer
F5 has different options.
I'll try the
setup with a runner here
E3 is a very interesting
idea. The idea is to play with the early queen B3
and force Black to
perhaps move the queen to C8.
Okay
J okay, you can
take it, well if you can't take it now,
but that's a stupid idea
look so dam C6 now he has
something then the 6 is hanging yes
no so now I want to play rook C8
probably
no yes you can actually keep the bp2 I would
also like to keep
no
but now a move like well now
invest another move here so  B3 no, that works, it works
very slowly,
no, come on, I have to put the piece
out there,
so, so, so,
without compensation,
of course, it's not what he has there. Rook
B4 and so he can muddle around a bit,
yes, knight C5, I can h should  I
probably also
take away like Rook
B2 so maybe you can play knight C6
or knight B5 and knight C6 things like that
on knight C5 I would have
also had knight F5 so knight C6
now
maybe well it
actually has to be good for white
or is  is still a pawn and
it's not clear to see what
black
has there, he can now take A7 all the time
and
so on.
You can
actually hit really stupid A7,
yeah
whoops, somehow it's always bad when
you make a move like that  I haven't seen
mine, it probably doesn't help either,
but it
's still stupid, well, probably run Z2 is
also really stupid,
but that's how he takes C4, now knight D6
wins a jellyfish or a queen rook,
yes, of course, as always, I was
slow and gave it a bit of gas. That
also helps  all the adjusters nothing from
him God what does the references
here also not seen at all Rook
A4 I now beat queen is hanging there
he also has to take my queen or
yes lu D6 okay can also
play my god what a
messy position so support me  the one
here like Queen
C8 Swap the
queen okay Queen C3 what
comes lu E5 or
what well anyway B2 is hanging C2
is hanging Bishop E5 ma I bishop
D4
yes I can too oh come on I'll take
the rook now the way doesn't matter so bishop E3
so
C2  so now there are two
qualities, yes, well, there is now
even more material lost with
all the
bindings, so let's do it so that
I can now exchange everything here,
yes, yes,
check, so now let's hope with the
attack on f7 now here quickly
win
check yes the arauer is also through check
and I
still have a bit of time also no so
checkmate well somehow
the game is very confusing despite the two
pawns that have been put away